[Musique]
un mur c'est l'histoire d'un mur qui
était la PL visible d'une guerre entre
deux mondes entre deux Allemagnes celle
de l'Ouest et l'autre celle de l'Est aux
mains des rouges en 1962 la guerre
froide entre le bloc soviétique et le
camp occidental atteint son
paroxisme alors on construit un mur qui
transformera Berlin Ouest en occidentale
au cœur de l'Allemagne
communiste deux Allemagnes c'est
peut-être une de trop mais ce mur lui
paraît
indestructible il faudra que gorbachchov
devienne le maître du kémelin en 1985
pour que soi lancés les premiers coups
de pioche mais on ne les voit
pas dès 86 plus tard 87 Gorbatchev a dit
clairement à tous les dirigeants
communistes de l'Europe de l'Est ce
qu'on appelait les démocraties
populaires qui n'était démocratique ni
ni populaire bon il aura dit très vite
jamais je n'emploirai la force pour
défendre vos
régimes donc c'est la la décision de
gorbatcheev qui entraîne la suite et dès
ce moment-là même si ce n'est pas public
il leur dit dans les réunions internes
dès 86 7 maximum tous ces régimes sont
des sont des morts en puissance en fait
ils le savent pas encore mais ce sont
déjà des des
[Musique]
zombies lorsque le 6 octobre 1989 miraë
gorbachov embrasse le dirigeant est
allemand Eric oneker c'est le baiser
d'un grand frère venu célébrer les 40
ans de l'Allemagne de
l'Est il ne sait pas encore que c'est en
réalité un baiser de la mort un mois
plus tard la estexister pres
[Applaudissements]
plus c'est sans conteste une rencontre
où des différents n'ont pas encore été
surmontés et il n'est pas sûr qu'il
puisse être surmonté mais il était
nécessaire de faire comme si tout allait
bien pour le
public quand on rencontre de haut
fonctionnaires soviétiqu là en
l'occurrence ce sont deux secrétaires
généraux qui se rencontrent on se sert
dans les bras et on
s'embrasse Gorbatchov est
arrivé ayant à la tête l'état réel de
l'Union soviétique et ayant des doutes
évidemment par des rapports du KGB et
d'autres sur l'état réel de la RDA et
pour lui il pensait que la RDA devait se
réformer pour pouvoir se maintenir
[Musique]
dans la soirée du 6 octobre 1989 les
Jeunesses communistes défilent devant le
patron de la
[Musique]
RDA imperturbable il entend la foule
scander le nom de
gorbachovi parqu la défte s'annonce mais
l'heure est à la fête et personne n'ose
imaginer que cette fête sera la
[Musique]
dernière c'était une
espérance à l'époque les jeunes en RDA
voyit en Gorbatchov l'espoir que les
structures figées se défassent que le
socialisme
évolue parmiux qui Scand le nom de
gorbach personne ne voulait
l'unitéemande
c'était simplement l'espoir que la RDA
puisse continuer à exister au travers de
l'Alliance soviétique et bien sûr le
fait est qu'on aurait préféré des
personnalités plus jeunes comme par
exemple gorbachov à la vieille équipe
que nous avions en
RDA et au moment du 40e anniversaire
avec toutous ces rassemblements et cette
retraite au flambau ces cérémonies
officiell et gorbev qui mon on pouvait
interpréter par c'est clair ça sent la
[Musique]
fin gorbachov profite de cet
anniversaire pour exhorter le Parti
communiste est allemand à se
transformer mais sa parole ne rencontre
aucun écho dans le
parti figé dans histoire
passé lui ne veut rien entendre et
continue de censurer tout évocation des
changements qui surviennent à
Moscou alors gorbachov va forcer le
destin de la RDA le temp
[Musique]
pressюльгатнь
мию не долгать
libérateur a allumé la mèche le
lendemain des jeunes descendent dans la
rue pour réclamer plus de
liberté la répre et jeune les
temples pendant que les dignitaires
communistes cherchent une issue
politique la rue enclenche un compte à
rebour dans toute l'Allemagne de
[Applaudissements]
l'Est je crois qu'au moment des
festivités du 40e
anniversaire les dirigeants n'avaient
pas prévu des manifestations d'une telle
ampleur alors qu'ils auraient dû être
informés par la stasie que
la colère était en train de monter au
sein de la
population mais à ce
moment-là il devaient encore croire
qu'ils allaient pouvoir contrôler la
situation que la majorité de la
population allait être de leur
côté mais les jours suivants alors que
les manifestations prenai de plus en
plus
d'ampleur on bien dû prendre conscience
qu'il n'avait plus le soutien de la
majorité de la
[Musique]
population l'Allemagne de l'Est a un
autre homme fort toujours dans le secret
toujours caché il s'appelle milk éic de
son prénom il est le patron de la stasie
la police politique du
régime il est réuni dans son bureau et
dans le plus grand secret plusieurs
dirigeants
estallemands jusqu'ici tout va
[Musique]
bien le 8 octobre il y a eu une réunion
à la
stasie elle était prévue pour que tout
soit bien en ordre pour que les
délégations présentes à l'occasion du
40e anniversaire de la RDA puisse
repartir dans de bonnes
conditions et lors de cette réunion j'ai
lu l'ébauche d'une déclaration que je
souhaitais soumettre au politebreau et
que j'ai d'ailleurs présenté le
lendemain et dans cette déclaration il
était écrit très clairement que les
problèmes politiques ne doivent pas être
réglés par la force mais que les
problèmes politiques doivent être réglés
de manière
politique autrement dit le 8
octobre ne clair pour tous les organes
de sûreté de la RDA qui stipulaent qu'il
ne pouvait y avoir de recours à la force
que si les manifestants devenaient eux
aussi
[Musique]
violents le 9 octobre c'est un lundi et
ce jour doit donner le coup d'envoi
d'une série de manifestations pour
réclamer l'avènement de la démocratie
les opposants décident de se retrouver à
leipig des amis nous av dit que ce lundi
il pourrait passer quelque chose à et
que ce lundi pourra être important un
jour crucial pour les semaines à venir
nousou F puisque nous savions que nous
étions les seuls à pouvoir le
[Musique]
faire manifémoign sont des choses
impossibles dans l'Allemagne de
l'Est cette police politique est
omniprésente tel un monstre
froid un état dans l'état une ville dans
la ville le grand mur en béton devant
l'entrée protège des regards
indiscrets le monde charge tourne en
permanence pour que les informations
remontent au plus vite les 100000 agents
et les quelques 200000 indicateurs en
font une arme redoutable qui fiche
espionne et surveille la stasie est une
araignée qui tend ses fils et profite de
ses yeux nombreux pour que rien ne lui
[Musique]
échappe dans mon appartement en
regardant par la fenêtre j'avais
remarqué que pendant des jours et des
jours la stasie me poursuivait en fait
il m'accompagnait quand je faisais mes
courses quand j'allais au bist TR il
m'accompagnait partout et tout le temps
pour limiter mon périmètre d'action pour
que je ne sois pas en mesure
d'agir et donc je me suis dit il faut
que je sorte de chez moi sans être suivi
alors j'ai installé des système de
minuterie sur les interrupteurs de mon
appartement pour que le soir la lumière
s'allume le téléviseur s'allume le
téléviseur s'éteigne la lumière
s'éteigne et en bas il pensait là il va
se coucher alors que j'étais déjà en
route pour
Leipzig profite de ruse par les toit à
lui la liberté et le pouvoir de
témoigner il se cache en haut d'un
clocher bravant le danger de la police
politique du haut de sa cachette il
filme les manifestants qui scandent nous
sommes le peuple et
gorbi ces images témoignent d'une
histoire incroyable celle d'un réveil à
l'est
quand nous étions tout en haut du
clocher de l'église et que nous avons vu
cette foule de manifestant Pacifique
quiandait nous sommes le peuple gorbatev
Gorbatchev on savait que si on arrivait
à faire passer ces images du côté ouest
elle serait diffusé le lendemain en RDA
par la télévision West
allemande mon copain m'a dit si ces
images passent demain à la télé ça ne
changera pas uniquement l'Allemagne et
la RDA ça changera le
monde
c'est une force incroyable qui se
dégageait de ces gens dans la rue et qui
nous parvenait jusqu'à se clocher et
c'était absolument pas ce que le pouvoir
avait dit un jour ce sont des farfelu
quelques ivrones qui manifestent là là
c'était la preuve que c'était le
[Musique]
peuple 20000 30000 50000 à stasie le
compteur s'affolle c'est la panique très
vite il faut se rendre à l'évidence ils
sont 70000 à défier le pouvoir policier
de la RDA du jamais vu la peur n'a pas
encore changé de camp mais le moment
fatidique
[Musique]
s'approche ce que nous craignons
pardessus tout c'est qu'il y a un bain
de sang que les dirigants du Parti
communiste recour au même méthod que les
chinis sur la
placein
199 soulagement quand nous avons reçu
cette information par un appel
téléphonique provenant de
l'ipz il y a des milliers de personnes
dans la rue et les forces de l'ordre
n'interviennent pas elles se sont
retirées
zbert a réussi à faire passer ses images
à
l'ouest le soir même ell ouvrent le
journal télévisé et pour le protéger le
présent est allemand dit que ces images
ont été tournées par une équipe
italienne le soulèvement est désormais
connu de part et d'autrre du rideau de
fer l'ampleur de ces manifestations
était pour nous une surprise une
surprise réelle parce que nous service
secret et d'autres sources nous avez pas
je dirais
expliqué je dirais l'état réel l'état
réelle ou la faiblesse réelle du régime
en RDA c'est vrai qu'à l'automne 89
nous avons été surpris comme tout le
monde comme d'ailleurs les les
dirigeants West allemands par la la
vitalité de d'une partie de ce peuple
d'Allemagne de l'Est qui n'avait pas
peur quoi qui qui n'avait plus
[Musique]
peur il y a urgence urgence à trouvé les
mots pour tenter d'enrayer le décompte
enclenché par la rue au siège du Parti
communiste est allemand on se réunit et
on tente de reprendre l'initiative après
l'agitation qui gagne le pays depuis le
succès de la manifestation du 9 octobre
et surtout il est urgent de tirer les
leçons d'un mouvement qui commence à
être
menaçant des dissensions au cœur du
pouvoir apparaissent le polbureau n'est
plus unanime et se lézarde sous la
pression de la
[Musique]
rue le 12 et le 13 octobre Eric coner a
tenu un conseil avec les premiers
secrétaires du parti et il n'était
absolument pas prédisposé à évoquer la
discussion qui avait eu lieu au sein du
politebreau suite au texte que j'avais
soumis il était simplement d'avis que
tout ça n'avait pas
d'importance et certains premiers
secrétair ont alors
protestéter le premier secrétaire dedam
s'est manifesté et a
dit cher camarade er coner dans
l'histoire de ce parti il y a un exemple
qui montre que lorsqu'on est plus en
mesure de diriger on passe la main à de
plus jeunes c'est ce que valterichait
fait avec toi et moi je t'invite à faire
de
même après cette
réunion me demande de venir dans son
bureau
là se trouve auss laence qui est le
premier secrétaire du parti
àst et membre du
polbauou les oreilles je souite demander
quelque chose à
h il me demande alors si je suis d'AV
qu'il est temps de
destituer et moi j'ai répondu très
clairement éliminé d'accord mais pour
qui et comment les appara sont orphelins
du chef et méfiant dans un monde où les
murs ont si souvent des
[Musique]
orill la situation a nettement
évolué et la distance visàvis de s
agrand mais la confiance qui règne entre
et moi n'est pas assz forte pour que
nous en
parlions Parti communiste l'heure est au
complot il faut se débarrasser du
camarade
oneker la prochaine réunion du
poltebreau est prévu les 17 et 18
octobre le Parti communiste entre dans
un affrontement qui prend des allures de
sauf qui peu la rue elle se donne
rendez-vous le 16
[Musique]
octobre
lorsque la manifestation du 16 octobre
débute l'air est étonnamment léger
etbert cache sa caméra dans un sac mais
il est descendu de son clocher pour se
mêler à la
rue des banderol commencent à apparaître
dans le
cortège les querelles et intrig de
palais au cœur même du parti communist
ont fini par laisser le champ libre au
[Musique]
manifestant
si le 16 tu sors par la porte d'entrée
pour aller à ta voiture et que tu ne
t'évades plus par le toi c'est que la
peur a
disparu et cette peur elle a fini par se
dissiper complètement pendant le trajet
vers leips puisqu'on avait pas doublé de
convois
militair donc on savait que dans la
ville il n'y aurait pas de grandes
unités militaires qui pourraient nous
inquiéter nous
menacer le 9 octobre quand on les
dépassait je trouvais ça angoissant de
ne pas savoir ce qui allait se passer et
bien sûr les manifestants sont eux aussi
devenus plus courageux ils étaient
incroyablement créatif avec des
banderoles et des
slogans au siège du Parti communiste à
Berlin les intrigue de palais ont repris
il s'agit de tout faire pour s'assurer
du renversement du camarade oneker le
[Musique]
ent convcre tous s camarades avant de
tirer les couteau on les
[Musique]
AFF nous avons discuté avec tout le
monde sauf
avec
gunterim
Herman en fait il n avait quimne qui
hés
bien
nér un chement à la tte Duti nétait pas
ce qui était le plus
compliqué ce qui était le plus compliqué
c'était de le mettre à
exécution j'ai parlé avec presque tous
les membres du politebreau lors de la
réunion du 17 octobre l'ensemble du Pol
bureau était
daver n'était plus en mesure de rester à
la tête du
parti con la rue berlinoise est elle
aussi agitée par des
manifestations et surtout l'opposition
se sent de plus en plus forte et
commence elle aussi à préparer le jour
d'après le 16 je n'étais pas à Leipzig
mais à Berlin il y avait beaucoup à
faire
aussi j'étais porte-parole dans notre
mouvement citoyen la démocratie
maintenant
c'était un groupe assez petit mais qui
formulait des thèses très précises et un
thème auquel nous nous consacrions était
la
réunification au PC comme à la stasie
l'heure est à l'inquiétude on sort les
dossiers et on tente de contrôler tous
les
agitateurs la répression comme horizon
l'ouverture comme moyen
politique P avoir préparé son coup
[Musique]
d'État le 18 octobre a lieu une réunion
du comité
central et lors de cette réunion il rne
une ambiance toute
particulière ma un urologue mondialement
connu membre du comité
central manifeste lui aussi de
il prononce ces mots qui aujourd'hui
encore me touch
beaucoup en tant que lieutenant de
l'armée rouge j'ai été un homme
courageux et j'ai combattu le fascisme
mais au sein du comité central je n'ai
jamais vraiment été courageux c'est pour
ça que je souite proposer et que je
demande au
camaradeer de se
retirer de conili en intri de
couloir pourvc en douceur le
camarade mais il nentend pas mourir seul
et surtout dans un ultime sursut propre
grand animaux de pouvoir il discrédite t
ses suceurs possibl par une manvre d'une
grande habé et totalement
[Musique]
désespér après ce
débatétait manifestement rendu compte
qu'il n'avait plus la confiance il alors
décidé de se retirer
h aujourd'hui je dirais tout
simplement il a déjou
rversement puis r luiême à la tribune et
annonce sa
démission c'est vrai que her a voté pour
sa propre
destitution cela est bien s lié à sa
fonction quand ilu plus personne ne le
soutenait au sein du
politeburereau il a alors voté
[Musique]
pour mais il a aussi dit une phrase très
intéressante aujourd'hui c'est moi et
demain ce sera vous qui devrait
partir l'honneur est sauf nul n'est
prophète en son pays dit-on mais on un
peu quand même il devine déjà que son
éviction ne constituera qu'un changement
dans la continuité pour le meilleur
pense-t-il l'histoire sera plus cruelle
[Musique]
encore mesdames et messieurs bonsoir
Egon krens est le nouveau premier
secrétaire général du parti il a été élu
C
après-midi le Comité central a accepté
Kerry coneker à sa demande soit libéré
de sa fonction en raison de son état de
senté il a été gracieusement remercié
pour son œuvre
politique meilleur ve pour votre
élection merci il y aura un discours ce
soir mais pourriez-vous déjà nous dire
quelques mots comment sent-on au début
d'une telle
étape j'aimerais dire pour le moment que
beaucoup de travail nous attend du
travail du travail vous voyez et encore
du
travail survient ensuite le problème
suivant un véritable scandale le fait
que her s'en aille et que le nouveau
secrétaire général arrive et s'adresse
au peuple en disant
ch montre tout simplement qu'on n pas
préparé qu'on sait pas vraiment quelle
direction prendre et qu'on fait comme si
soud tout le peuple était devenu membre
du Parti
communiste
Gewand zur Wahrheit zu der wir stehen
gehört auch dass wir unbeirr gesetzeste
fgenzialismus dieze humanistische alter
[Musique]
en fait j'arrive même pas à mettre des
mux là-dessus abattu abattu non ça on
l'était pas puisquon éétait pas tombé à
terre mais peut-être qu'on peut le dire
simplement comme ça on arrivrivait tout
simplement pas à y
croire onarait tout simplement pas à y
croire on pvait prendre Act et secouer
la tête puis laisser passer nuit se
demandit pendant quelques jours comment
serait l'avenir de ce pays avec ce crens
Gon krens a réussi la parachic intrigant
est devenu le maître de la RDA mais Eric
kcker ne peut en réalité se résoudre à
quitter le pouvoir et c'est en toute
camaraderie qu'il aura l'éloge mortel
Egon Kens est le meilleur pour me
succéder dira-t-il
manière de saperer les débuts de son
[Musique]
successeur je ne sais pas s'il l'a fait
siamment mais c'est évident que c'est
pour ça que les gens dans la rue voyent
en moin le PE le mais en plus grand à
cause de ma
taille en tout
cas a clairement contribuugmenter
l'tilité la RDA et aussi dans le parti
il a montré en quelque sorte que le
changement qui s'était opéré là n'était
pas
sol en fait c'était un non
événement nous étions certes
contents été
remplacé mais que ce soit justement qui
devienne son
successeur ça c'était une
plaisanterie que ce devienne le chef du
gouvernement et du parti lui qui avait
applaudi la solution chinoise ça c'était
tout à fait inadmissible
on Kens n'est pas le nouveau maître de
Berlin est il est tout simplement un
chiffon rouge qui cristallise toutes les
oppositions et pousse les manifestants à
descendre dans la rue dès le lendemain
de sa prise de
[Musique]
fonction plus tard il y a eu une
caricature où on voyait Gon krens avec
une tête de loup qui disait Mère Grand
pourquoi as-tu dei grande
dents donc personne en RDA du moins pas
nous l'opposition ceux qui militaient
pour les droits civies n'avaient la
moindre confiance en
lui et on était d'avis que si c'était
vraiment lui les choses ne pouvaient
alors
qu'empirer en fait ce n'était pas le
vieillard oner qui prend le volant et
qui fonce dans un arbre en défonçant
tout sur son passage non non c'était un
presque
sexagénère en fait nous on se disait
c'est terrible terrible donc adieu les
réformes adieu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
GB après les 9 et 16
octobreourne àig mais comm
desliers ce plus la rue n'appartient
plus au pouvoir ni même à la tristement
célèbre stasie mais au peuple
estem et je crois que l'imagination des
manifestants avaitelle aussi ses
limites on va où là ça va mener à quoi
bon d'accord le gouvernement va
peut-être dégager mais
après et oui la peur é toujours présente
c'est clair cette peur a fini par se
dissiper mais elle était toujours un peu
là d'ailleurs on voit ces gens au visage
crispé qui finissent par oser lancer
quelques mots à la caméra ou qui soudain
se montrent très courageux ou qui ne
reculent plus brusquement pour éviter
qu'on les
filme à chaque jour sa manifestation la
rue ne désemplit
plus Berlin hienna toutes les villes est
allemandes sont en
ébullition face à cela le pouvoir
politique multiplie les intrigues dans
un sauf qui peu général le temps va trop
vite au parti communiste chacun joue sa
carte et les forces de l'ordre
témoignent d'une bienveillance toute
nouvelle pour les
[Musique]
opposantseef undu
die
menlich lorsquun pouvoir politique per
pied il envoie son porte-parole et les
communistesem ENT
gunterabski c'est à lui d'exliquer une
politique dont plus personne ne veut de
masquer le désar des dirigs il le fera
avec une loyauté intacte au nom de sa
fidélité au nom aussi de son
ambition monsieursk bonsoir et un grand
merci de vous rendre disponible à he
tardive vous avez parl ce midi avec le
pasteur for vous avez mis en perspective
un changement un renouvellement du droit
de manifester pourz-vous
préciser nous considérons la rue n'est
pas l'endroit approprié pour le
dialogue dialogj commenc les
citoyens il y a de nombreuses
possibilités de s'exprimer de partager
leur points de vue leurs
propositions je suis certain que cette
prise de conscience va s'imposer parmi
la majorité de nos concitoyens et nous
aurons de moins en moins à parler de ce
qui se passe dans la
[Musique]
rue la délience d'un pouvoir parfois
comme un révélateur sur les hommes
gunterabovski laisse désormais parler
son ambition il joue sa carte se rvant
unique rescap du CH
[Musique]
politique ich
m wie wir dieosition
[Musique]
einzen
maisabski n'est pas le seul tout ce
confond faut-il sauver sa tête au cas où
le régime s'effondre ou bien fautil
sauver le régime pour mieux se
protéger cette question h désormais tous
les dirigeants
estemands nhésite pas à descendre dans
la rue au côté des
[Musique]
oppos le maire de drest Wolfgang berof
je prépare à une
manifestation et là à drest nous avons
essayé de lancer un
dialogue nous avons organisé TR grandes
manifestations des représentants des
partis et des mouvements ont pris la
parole nous avons donc inié un
dialogue en faisant circuler des micros
parmi les
participants pour qu'il puisse poser des
questions et alimenter le
[Musique]
débat
aon Kens part chercher de l'aide à
Moscou il sait que les temps ont changé
et que le soutien du kremelin ne peut
qu'être
qu'économique de quoi satisfaire les
exigences de la rue et relancer
[Musique]
habe e
historcheah de
aret n im
engterluchiousin
puisque nous ne voulions pas que la RDA
prenne le chemin qu'avait pris la
Hongrie ou la Pologne à savoir que nous
ne voulions pas dépendre du FMI ou de la
Banque mondiale car sinon un renouveau
ou une évolution du socialisme n'aurait
pas été
envisageable le voyage de K à Moscou à
l'époque début novembre n'est pas resté
inaperçu et nous étions plus ou moins au
courant de l'état réel de l'Union
soviétique surtout de ses finances et de
l'économie et c'était clair que gorbatov
ne pouvait pas aider
k gorbachchov m'a dit que l'Union
soviétique était elle aussi dans une
situation difficile et il m'a également
dit tu sais si je te communiquais les
chiffres effectifs de notre budget de la
défense ce que nous dépensons pour les
autres pays et pour le programme
militaire de guerre des
si j'additionnais tout ça tu serais
surpris et tu ne demanderais même pas si
nous sommes en mesure de venir en aide à
la
RDA à l'époque il m'a dit très
clairement nos problèmes nous ne pouvons
les résoudre que conjointement et il a
également suggéré que les relations
commerciales se fassent à tro entre la
RDA l'Union soviétique et la République
fédérale
d'Allemagne
le kemelin n'a plus les moyens d'être le
bailleur de fond d'une RDA à l'agonie
mais surtout le camarade gorbachov
pousse les dirigeants estallemands à
s'entendre avec ceux de l'Allemagne de
l'Ouest et depuis presque toujours le
voisin de l'Ouest est prêt à aider mais
en exigeant des dirigeants est Allemands
des
réformes plus de démocratie plus de
liberté pour les Allemands de
l'Est le sait il y aura un prix à payer
il ne sait pas encore qu'il sera
énorme CR a pris contact avec nous avec
la Mane de l'Ouest dans les journées
après pour avoir de l'aide et nous
étions ou
fond prêt à aider la RDA
moyennant ce que j'appelle
l'ouverture humanitaire et démocratique
d'avantage oui
dans nos discussions avecon et h nous
avons toujours insisté sur le point
suivant la RFA est prête à apporter
d'importantes aides financières si
Berlin Est change radicalement sa
politique à savoir réforme économique
ouverture des frontières liberté de
voyager et élection
[Musique]
libre
le 4 novembre restera sans doute à
jamais comme l'épilogue de ce mois
d'agitation il y a moins d'un mois les
Jeunesses communistes défil dans une
retraite au flambau maintenant ce sont
les écrivains qui appellent à une
immense manifestation réclamant le droit
au voyage il seront million une
démonstration de force à laquelle
certains dirig tent désespérément de se
raccrocher comme le désormais célèbre
guntersk
bitter
essere auch anine
adresse nur W mnung hört
undsteh
ist zuem
Anfang wir alle
[Musique]
wollendr
[Applaudissements]
mheostraabski ambitionn mais je vais
dire Sansour de rester dans les affaires
et puisquil était malin forcment
intelligent il s'est dit si tu prends la
parole ici tu as des chances de rester à
la tête du parti communiste et c'est
exactement ce qu'il a fait il est
carriériste et
aventurier en tout cas il était à
l'époque c'est
évident c'était aussi
quelqu'un de
superficiel c'était quelqu'un qui en
fait ne comprenait pas lui-même ce qu'il
faisait comment devait se comporter pour
accéder aux
responsabilités je dirais que ce n'était
pas une manifestation de
l'opposition mais toute la conception de
cette manifestation était un compromis
avec les anciens
dirigeants qui effectivement ont pris la
parole pour un grand nombre d'entre eux
et qui voulait saisir
l'opportunité d'afficher un nouveau
visage pour regagner un peu de
crédibilité à un moment donné je me suis
dit et pourquoi on irait pas tous à la
porte de
brandbourg pourquoi ce millions de
personnes s'arrêteil à 500 m de la porte
de brandbourg et se dirige-t-il vers un
autre endroit pourquoi on ne passerait
pas tout simplement sous la porte de
brandbourg comme ça l'affaire aurait été
réglée mais bon personne n'y a pensé
peut-être parce qu'il y avait beaucoup
de camarades de la stasie qui défilaient
et que ça ne pouvait pas leur venir à
l'esprit droit au voyage la rue c'est
poumon et on krens veut taccorder ce
droit pour trouver une solution à la
contestation pour répondre aux exigences
de l'Allemagne de l'Ouest en échange
d'argent la rue déborde et lui
on Kens seul dans son bureau envisage de
jouer un coup poker dans un dilemme
terrible lui lapparachic qui doit tout à
la RDA doit permettre aux femmes et aux
hommes de
laquitter il va ouvrir les frontières de
l'Allemagne de l'Est il faut dire que
ces frontières sont devenues un peu des
passoir depuis le début de l'été la
Tchécoslovaquie et la Hongrie sont
traversés par des Allemands qui vont
ensuite en Autriche dans une folle ruée
vers l'ouest avec toujours la peur au
ventre mais l'ardent désir d'être libre
[Musique]
cette conquête d'un nouveau monde hier
encore ennemi et depuis 40 ans interdit
Egon Kens veut y répondre favorablement
il joue en réalité non pas un coup de
poker mais un vatou sur fond
d'impuissance politique et de tension
entre
[Musique]
camarades
le 9 novembre le Comité central se
réuni entend bien imposer sa dernière
carte très vite les mot du patron
communiste de la RDA sont ceux d'une
[Musique]
ouverture
ast wie
früerar im
anst une information sous forme de
communiqué de presse alors é
élaboré j'ignore comment sont
arrang ont fait
concrètement le fait est et ça je le
sais
précisément que ce communiqué de
presse ne devait être rendu public que
le 10 novembre à 5h de
[Musique]
l'après-midi au moment où Schabowski
allait se rendre à sa conférence de
presse il m'a demandé il y a-t-il
quelque chose dont tu voudrais que je
parle je lui ai alors donné cette
déclaration que j'avais lu devant le
Comité central et qui avait été approuvé
en supposant qu'il sacheent lire et
qu'il ne disent pas autre
chose car lui en tant commomme des
médias il savait parfaitement que si
quelque chose est publiée alors on peut
dire dès maintenant immédiatement mais
si je le publie le 9 alors il faut dire
à partir de
demain
alors on m'a informé qu'un communiqué a
été distribué
aujourd'hui vous devez être en sa
possession des voyages privés vers
l'étranger peuvent donc être demandés
sans condition sans donner les raisons
du voyage ou sans avoir des relations
familiales des accords seront donnés
dans un bref délai des sorties du pays
peuvent être effectué par toutes les
frontières de la RDA vers la RFA est-ce
aussi valable pour Berlin Ouest oui oui
les sorties permanentes peuvent avoir
lieu partir de tous les points
frontaliers vers la RFA ou bien par
Berlin Ouest quand est-ce que cela
rentre en vigueur à ma connaissance ça
rentre en vigueur tout de suite
immédiatement dans ce polce bureau
c'était le chaos personne ne savait
vraiment ce qu'il avait été décidé les
médias ont repris cette phrase de
shabowski et ensuite la situation est
devenue incontrôlable et les gens ont
afflué vers les postes frontière les
douigners n'ont reçu aucun soutien
aucune information de la part de leurs
ministres respectifs
tout c'est compliqué les gens ne se sont
pas rendus à la frontière pour prendre
d'assut le mur comme cela est dit
aujourd'hui mais en y ayant été pour
ainsi dire invité par
shabovski c'est des situation l'histoire
s'accélère plus aucun pouvoir n de
pouvoir donc il a pas y a pas
surinpréter ce qui s passé ce qui est S
c'est qu'au
postfontière les policiers qui contrôler
les fameuses forces qui avaient tiré sur
tellement de de malheureuses personnes
de de berlinis qui tentaient de franchir
le mur il y a beaucoup de morts B les
les les enfin les les les successeurs
les remplaçants de ces de ces forces de
police ils ont pas osé tirer ils ont pas
ils ont même pas laissé euh osé laisser
la porte fermée donc ils ont ouvert ils
ont demandé des instructions alors
hiérarchie qui s'était désintégré ils
sont tombés sur deux trois types qui ont
dit j'en sais rien fais comme tu peux
c'est la fin c'est la c'est la
désagrégation et je vois encore
aujourd'hui ce policier Gard frontière
en uniforme qui éta dressé là et qui
secou la tête comme
ça etutre qui était dans gu habituement
ilérif les passeport qui dis moi je fais
plus rien aujourd'hui je fais plus
rien et tout à coup onetrouvé côéouest
cétait complètement
fou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que s'est-il passé dans la tête de
Gunter shabowski est-ce de la
précipitation de l'ignorance ou du
calcul un mauvais calcul on ne le saura
jamais ce mot malheureux appartient
désormais à l'histoire comme le signe
tragique de la
fin le temps c'est en réalité à arrê
pour les dirigeants est allemands mais
il continue pour la
[Musique]
rue j'étais à une fête d'anniversaire
dans le quartier du
princeerberg et à cette fête tout à coup
il n'y a plus de vin quelqu'un a alors
dit qu'il descendait en chercher dans le
bistr qui se trouvait juste en bas de
l'appartement puis il est revenu dans
l'appartement avec qure bouteilles de
il était
blme et
dit il s'est passé quelque
chose le patron a payé sa tournée de
bière à tout le monde et la patronne est
en train de pleurer près du
comptoir et tout le monde pousse des
cris de
joie il paraît que le mur est
ouvert nous avons alors allumé la télé
et on a vu et revu ce moment oùskisait
son papier imement la possibilité de
voyager et nous bon qu'est-ce qu'on
fait on est monté à bord de deux
trabants et on s'est rendu à la porte de
brandbourg ou pendant un la de
temps je crois que c'était entre minuit
et 3h du
matin il y avait la possibilité de
[Musique]
sa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et tout Berlin était dans le même état
sur leam on faisait péter le champagne
et les gens criaient pleuraient et
riaent il se serraent dans les bras oui
c'était c'est tout simplement
indescriptible
céit parfois il y a des choses
qu'onarrive pas à
décrires coup onarrive plus à
décrire la naissance de mes enfants tu
ne te souviens plus bien car c'est un
sentiment que tu n'arrives plus à
décrire et tu n'arrives pas non plus à
décrire c'est quelques pas qui te mène
vers la liberté en fait aujourd'hui
encore ça marage des larmes c'est aussi
simple que ça c'est indescriptible il y
a comme ça quelques instants de la vie
pour lesquels il n'y a pas de mot tout
simplement parce qu'ils ne sont pas
saisissables il n'y a plus qu'un Berlin
et bientôt il n'y aura plus qu'une
Allemagne c'est la fin de l'Allemagne
communiste un pays ne peut exister sans
frontière et ce soir du 9 novembre
unetière a disar au terme d'un décomte
enclenché un mois plus tôt un décomte
fatal le mur n'existe plus ce n'est pas
la fin de l'histoire mais plutôt la fin
d'une
histoire le matin j'ai pu retourner à
Berlin est même sans passeport pour
aller réveiller mes enfants à
6h puis on les a
habillé emmené à
l'école on les a pris par la main et on
s'est rendu au poste-fontière de la born
holmstrace pour repasser ensuite du côté
ouest et entres le soleil s'est
élevé et
nous on était ébah devant les étalages
des primeurs
et on regardait ces différents fruits
qui poussent à travers le monde mais que
nous onit encore jamais vu et con non ni
le
goût puis on est allé dans des
librairies et on avait des larmes dans
les yeux devant tout ce qu'on pouvait
acheter
là et voilà c'est comme ça que nous
avons passé notre première journée à
Berlin
[Musique]
Ouest
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]